delivery  that seems not normal  hi unjoined probably a bad guy oh this  is adorable  hey stop zapping me with your little  wizard stick it's cold our stuff looks  like somebody just got mugged  why don't we call a truce and you tell  me what's going on  perhaps that would be the wisest course  of action okay so here's the deal  there's this real bad dude wears a  helmet  he's been tearing rifts between all the  Lego worlds Wow  I only understood about half of that but  it sounds pretty bad and he's got our  friends so we must return to our quest  to save them  still working out the kinks with a  remote function we could use your help  rebuilding our vehicle stretch no  problem well nice meeting you whatever  your name is  many thanks for your assistance good  Liege ironed good luck  I think I just swallowed a Batarang